Chinese consumers aren't the only ones
keeping an eye on prices economists are
too China has entered a period of
disinflation for the second time this
year stimulus measures have failed to
encourage spending the shrinking uh
property uh value uh which is caused by
the the collapse of the real estate
bubble may have uh uh bad psychological
effects on the uh those that have real
estate so uh they may
expect expect that their uh asset value
is shrinking and then uh uh their future
plans uh for uh consumption will be uh
cut down the Consumer Price Index
dropped 0.2% in October weighed down by
a recent slump in pork prices a result
of over Supply in early October the
World Bank C its 2024 growth forecast
for China as it struggles with a
property sector crisis and an
increasingly uncertain economic Outlook
according to research by JP Morgan and
Bloomberg developers accounting for 40%
of home sales have defaulted on their
debt since 2021 amounting to $15
billion that's casting a shadow over the
economy contributing to Consumers
reluctance to spend big this week the
international monetary fund revised up
its forecasts for China for this year
and next it predicts growth to slow to
4.6% in 2024 as weakness in the real
estate sector persists and external
demand remains
subdued despite the challenges there are
some positive indicators including early
signs of improvement in the relationship
between the US and
China and the thriving renewable energy
sector
I'm very optimistic about China's
economy and our company's future China's
economy has kept growing for many years
our industry's demands on the market are
gradually increasing every year the
annual growth is about 20% so we are
very
confident such attitudes are welcome in
China as it tries to return to brighter
economic prospects Jessica Washington
aler chongu
China make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer